whoa mm-hmm talking about Coachella
weekend playing hey what's going on
everybody for first we feast I'm Sean
Evans and you're watching hot ones it's
the show with hot questions and even
hotter wings and today we're joined by
Liza Koshi
she's one of the internet's biggest
superstars with tens of millions of
subscribers a few billion views between
a pair of channels and you can also
catch her in the second season of Liza
on demand which is out now on YouTube
premium Liza Koshi welcome to the show
yeah thank you my favorite thing is your
eyebrow when you switch cameras oh it is
an honor to be here you notice the big
small things no oh it's big small loving
big or small do you actually carry hot
sauce in your bag like how's your spice
tolerance oh man I wish I had my bag
here I do not have hot sauce in it today
but I'm a Cholula type girl which is
mostly like sodium but I like it like a
little dab of that sauce on my food when
I travel
[Music]
[Music]
okay here we go all of a sudden I'm
hungry
diving in mr. Luna
[Music]
some good chicken right there he's a
pretty good wing today right wings today
I'm on the right day yeah he came on the
right - you shamed them for the other
episode yeah good
this is moist says we touched on your
intro you have a pair of channels Liza
Koshi and Liza Koshi - combined 25
million Plus subscribers billions of
views what's the biggest slap on the
wrist that you've ever gotten filming
inside a grocery or big-box store I got
kicked out of my cab three ideas yikes
mm-hmm Burbank the other one in Burbank
because there was two open at the same
time at one point and then there was
another one like 12 miles away but I got
kicked out of it because I was doing the
worm and they saw me on the security
camera man kick yep
Liza's doing the worm and then yep
they've repelled down the walls and not
and took you out in handcuffs yeah
that's way though cuz the security guard
like watched my videos and was like let
me stop you gotta get out
I didn't finish that one but I might
finish the rest oh she's good as she
does she have like green chili peppers
do you know the language of origin or
this one so it's funny you mentioned
that this is actually inspired by me mmm
so small acts made that sauce for this
I'm from Chicago so they're doing like
this like sort of jardin ARA sort of run
it through the garden hot dog put some
wheels on it hot sauce I see you now you
look like that's good that's good so in
my humble opinion the red carpet
interview it's the most daunting
assignment and all of media there's no
way to prepare yourself for everything
that gets thrown at you the speed of it
it is so fast and then the assignment is
literally trying to get a usable
soundbite from someone walking by you
trying to get into the party mm-hmm
how would you detail the ups and downs
of that experience at the Met Gala where
all of those knobs are cranked up to ten
you're so well-spoken I enjoy
conversation very much thank you
you make me wish I went two more years
of college so that I could be more of
just that one where'd I go to school
hold on you went to school do your
research you say you do I do I do
so it was it was in Texas yeah come on
go for it you're talkin like Texas State
or something no University of Houston
University of you go Cougars ups and
downs are literally the stairs that
people come up on because I have to see
Madonna walk from the very bottom of the
carpet all the way up the stairs for
each person that walks up it's just that
level of anxiety that you're trying to
like subdue so that you can just be a
human in front of them
I definitely changed per person like
when Harry Styles get off - it was not
the same reaction like hello
mr. Harry Styles and I went to like an
English accent of sorts I don't know I
was like trying to make him feel more at
home or comfortable or something I might
have it offensive but it's like what is
it like interviewing Kim Kardashian when
Kanye is doing that Kanye thing where
he's standing next to her looking bored
on the carpet funny enough so they
weren't thank you for acknowledging my
truth that's literally what everybody
was saying um in the comments on the
interview
but it was basically like Kanye came up
and Kanye said to me like hey I'm not
gonna be answering any questions
tonight's her night tonight's about her
cameras were not rolling there's no
proof of any of this y'all think I'm
lying I know but that's that's exactly
what he said so then I just all my
attention was at her and then I threw a
compliment to him at the end and made
Kanye smile
all hell's about to break loose yeah
yeah I know I'm gonna turn it up at some
point I know so it is worth pointing out
you're from Houston Texas is it hard to
get a good fajita here in Los Angeles
it's not possible shine no I know what
good Vegeta's okay that's how you
probably say it so good fajitas are
basically marinated in pineapple and
lime juice the acidity breaks it down
makes her a real tender real soft real
juicy it's a fantastic time tex-mex
that's good food do you remember what it
was like when vine hit Lamarr high
school it was my junior year it was 17
this app came out and everybody was
downloading it and I gave in to peer
pressure and downloaded it to he's just
like I'm gonna make some video sharing
with my six friends it's kind of like a
big group Chet did being popular like on
social media does that translate to
being popular in the classroom like
could you see some sort of shift within
the school walls um I was pretty
obnoxious in real life throughout my
high school experience and so when vine
kind of happened
people just it was a pretty normal like
extension of your person yeah they're
like okay yeah she's just doing the same
thing but online and then when it
started taking off people were asking me
what I was doing or how it was doing it
but they treated me the same that can be
helpful keep it all in Houston Texas
alright what's this one Lowe's calientes
oh it was there I'm thoroughly enjoying
myself so you're part of a very small
group of internet stars who parlayed
their success on the platform to enter
the world of TV and film why do you
think beyond the bag there's still this
lore for creators to work with networks
when the audience that you can build
independently will smash most cable
channels I'll be right back we'll be
right back after these messages
um I think honestly it's just at least
for me it was a way for me to like
experiment outside of my own home I'm
like I made all my videos by myself and
for me that was like isolating
experience where I was like talking to a
wall instead of a person so for me it
was exciting to step into double-dare
and host on nickelodeon because i got to
perform in front of kids have you
learned how to balance the sort of
expertise of others versus your own
instincts because I'm not as deep into
it as you are but at least from what I
can kind of gather from experiencing
things you know like there's this weird
sort of thing where the network the
production company and the individual
right the creator we all have the same
goal yeah but then the network might be
like you know hey we're paying for this
like we have the final say so the
production company's like we're building
this we have the final say and then you
might say well hey I've built this
audience you came knocking on my door
like maybe you should listen to me more
yeah and that's where I get very picky
with the experiences that I have right
like I have to make sure that whatever
whoever I'm aligning with or working
with I truly do a lot with them and that
I'm given a blank canvas as an artist
she's some harness you study and and be
like my authentic self and my own
personality which is what people have
apparently think you have likes so
that's what's cool about like my
experience with Nickelodeon my
experiences though they really trusted
me and trusted my voice to like bring
something
to their network or channel
[Music]
her less horseradish
[Music]
I thought that in my nostrils first yeah
it's it's cranking up a little bit here
mm-hmm mm-hmm my lips especially call
assumption right there hey thanks good
looking out Liza of course I got you
there anything my good you're clean
you're clean
okay go oh I'm gonna keep going there
you go
warrior spirit mm-hm highs are we ever
current segment on our show called
explain that Graham where you do a deep
dive on our guest Instagram poll
interesting pictures that need more
context so we will put up the first
picture on the monitor you just tell us
the bigger story good can you give us
the BTS I'm taking a picture with jared
leto severed head jared leto and i did
an interview for the mat and he came up
and he said my interview with you last
year you you're funny
oh my god I couldn't even like process
the information cuz his eyes we're
looking at me yeah his eyes do and the
compliment that he gave to me cut that
out
Anna personally I did that when I swear
but afterwards I saw him at the party
and he like Ranger just himself again
and he was just so sweet and I was like
please take a picture of you with your
head so I got a two-for-one that it was
he walking around the gala like just
holding that thing or like would it go
out on the table while he went to the
bar like was it traveling with him it
was traveling everywhere with him so he
was like in a booth or in the same booth
as me in that club that was a corner of
the club and it was just chilling next
to him I think he had his arm around him
yeah I think he had his arm around I'm
gonna go for that cuz that's a better
story what's the backstory on the buns
out the literal backstory the literal
backstory okay yeah so my booty was out
Anna gave you five options like five
different like black dresses and I chose
that lacy option I thought I was
beautiful and I thought I was going to
be wearing shorts underneath it and
instead we went with like a thong option
and then I think it was a reverend that
showed up to the mat or somebody and we
slid on shorts so damn fast and then the
religious figure passed by and then we
took him on
scorpion for pepper sauce plant I have
so much chicken all over my nails I'm
taking leftovers home baby baby ooh okay
let's go
I regret that being on my lip it's gonna
burn mmm
right an emotional rollercoaster this
one always every day now she's opening
my eyes for the edit I was hoping that
like scary music was playing over that
if not do it again here we go
[Music]
getting real over here I've been taking
two bites at each wanna continue that
pattern we're ready me right now yep so
the why I quit YouTube video is kind of
two vloggers what the why I'm leaving
New York essay is to writers is it
almost a requisite part of being a
creator these days you think that part
of that arc is shutting off the faucet
for a while I think so I think just as
like
up oh no I'm good I'm waiting for myself
to get high be careful around your eyes
this is the part where I have to remind
people even though like it might be hard
for you to even touch your eye like if
they want to take it it's hard to touch
my eye
this is maybe a good thing right now
anybody with acrylic nails is making
strong life decisions I cannot feel
below my nose okay um what's question I
think that you you need to take a break
and kind of like pull out of the reality
that you've created for yourself I'm
just kind of like examine life for a
second and for me I needed to go like
live life and just let myself breathing
appreciate it myself
and the world and like just travel and
like became our cultured so I can come
back and create my characters with
accents based off of the people I study
whatever and then you've done some
videos where you'll react to teens
reacting to you or you'll read Mead
comments about yourself
wait is that wet underneath there real
quick little moisture going on a little
moisture there good little wet lip do
you have a hack for how to separate
constructive criticism from just like
the unhinged weirdo angry energy mmm
it's a skill and it's tough skin I'm
just inking might as well answer this
question go ahead the skill and there
are some that's just gonna be criticism
and then there's some that are like
constructive criticism and you know that
too cuz it's nice that it's like a focus
group you know like some people pay so
much money to get the information that
like your audience just provides you for
free and now and then I think it helps
with their connection to the show
because they're actively shaping and
informing what they see then they're
closer to it than like anything that
they'd watch on TV but yeah there's some
give and take to that right sure and
they're you and you definitely
to like make a filing cabinet in your
brain of like these comments are like
hurtful and I'm okay emotionally in tune
and I feel everything and I'm an empath
but that's okay
I think Instagram is like a more
positive place let go and like you
compliments like yo you look great or
congratulations on getting engaged with
but YouTube is more like okay I'm
creating and the Creator wants feedback
different worlds you're going on to like
different worlds Twitter's Twitter is
pay you needed that's where the most
smoke is a lot of a lot of therapeutic
releases on that on that platform well
speaking of smoke God that was a good
transition hey Paul you're good they
don't teach that
[Music]
[Music]
guess where it's made Houston Texas
baby that's right come on it's gonna be
good
whoo oh yeah the effects over that one
was good huh damn your editors are good
giving them a lot to work with
huh it's like I'm gonna see my future
self like Papa and warn me like don't do
this it's a bad move I didn't like
disappear behind a lot she tried to stop
me but she can't be stopped
I'm going back in as someone who split
their time between Texas New York and
Los Angeles can you rank the following
restaurants from best to worst oh my god
give it to me this is fun
Shake Shack in and out Whataburger Oh
Kimmy okay
Whataburger number one no question
people from Texas rides so hard for
Whataburger oh so hard like I don't
understand why it's compared Whataburger
and in and out cuz in and out you just
get a basic burger water burger you get
whatever your heart desires what a book
is fantastic they have a patty melt they
have all this like like a chicken tender
sandwich it's a good time honey butter
chicken biscuit delicious in and out
then Shake Shack only because I love
animal fries like when animal fries like
cool down and it's just all like one big
chunk stuck together that's how I like
to eat it all right bring in another
napkin real quick thank you have you
seen this one girl what is happening to
this crust over here I throw this in the
trash okay cool no I take good care of
my napkin it's been like this the whole
time
real quick a Whataburger animal-style
that'd be dope oh there you go yeah
never pretty spanking good dude
yeah okay de bomb I know you know oh I
know but watch this damn show Shawn
alright let's do it let's do it okay
oh that's what you do that's what you do
so you don't eat it five seconds
do you wanna cheers Cheers
okay the bomb my life choices
are you doing over there pretty good
holding up it's my responsibility I feel
I'm so glad around it's like I won't
turn red unless there's an effect Colin
turn out now
Krieger [ __ ] turn that knob do it god I
was a con you're great yes he's
wonderful Colin Higgins doesn't get
enough love yeah go call it should I
said bit my lip a couple days ago it's
still healing up yes there is the balm
reminded you is it the crevasses are you
going back in her yeah
what's the weirdest YouTube genre that
you've ever discovered on accident
recently I've found this guy and he just
sits motionless for hours on end who
does that
did you subscribe no but his views are
pretty good he doesn't that's a lot more
saliva then I thought I could produce
yeah but I think I think the weirdest
I've seen was like Dahl dissecting it's
just like a psychopath and making right
there but they literally like would take
syringes and put them into dolls and it
was like you were playing doctor I miss
that kind of way but you ain't you
didn't really play a doctor yeah
Internet so you really played the
Internet so we're facing about anything
which Creator do you think as the most
fervent fanbase hmm my instinct is to
say Peter back because he has the
biggest fan base on YouTube and they're
just like so devoted to him they
constantly support him and then I know
that you're very self-deprecating when
it comes to your celebrity impressions
but one that you think is actually
pretty good
ah this is a really bad joke you ready
for it mm-hmm okay I would say that I
remember after your suffering
it's my Beyonce impression mixed with an
awful joke when Beyonce asks jay-z a
question what does she say what did she
say
jy
[Music]
what's nice is like I look into your
eyes and you've done this many times but
you you look like yours and you're
scared to take that by two jacks I done
it many times Luke you coming back
sounds like a president problem Walt
what am I gonna do you know buddy you
have this is my favorite show my
favorite area yeah
there's like a compilation of you
getting complements by the way have you
ever need an ego boost it's on you all
some ain't know it and sometimes I do
sometimes I do Wow Pokemon Coachella
I'm sure we can play how do you explain
tick tock to a fully grown adult chicken
wing talk show host who has no idea
what's going tick-tock has had an
evolution I will say it's really
interesting to watch because it was
originally called musically tick tock
now I think it's like today's mine it's
becoming this place for people to create
sketches and like make really funny
videos you burpin off camera I guess I'm
burping on camera oh nice that's okay
that's how you do it mmm when vine died
did you mourn it oh my god yeah
pulling out every time every time I will
pour out the drinks that we have not
touched by the way Hey
I think we're good cause some shrapnel
mmm still there
you're good nothing you're good I miss
it so much I actually created a whole
another account on Instagram just to
upload really short videos that are
about like six to 12 seconds long and to
is like if you're in like all these
different platforms I guess on something
like vine which is so massively popular
yeah and then launches so many people's
careers but then it can disappear like
that yeah and it literally did man
everybody got fired I don't know
whatever the app just like was like okay
we're taking this down everybody's
resumes we're just gone right anything
they had ever really created other than
like it living and continuing to live on
YouTube boom
let's go let's go
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last way I
know it looks literally like what about
the see you don't have to if you don't
want to oh I'm going to I know that I
almost said that with you word for word
damn here we go cheers Cheers
I really doesn't like doo doo doo doo
sauce we might change the name I'm not
letting that touch my lips
[Music]
whoa that flavors I'm sorry go ahead
congratulate me okay Liza Koshi here we
are at the end of our trip down the wing
gauntlet but before we put a bow on this
episode I think that's important that we
hear from some of the other characters
and little Isaac oh she universe so if
you'll humor me
mm I'll hit you with some prompts you
know then you can channel these liza
Koshi alter egos okay okay hey jet how
do you think Liza handle their spice
today pretty good mitties blazing I know
that that's the way she liked it sorry I
did open my mouth for Helga if you're a
guest in season 11 what do you think
you'll have to do to outperform Liza not
shoot a break afterwards like she's
going through and then little Liza are
you proud of what lies has become look
at her eating scorching hot chicken
wings here on YouTube could make me cry
man yeah I'm really proud she's a really
good job she was really nervous what
started this and right now there's some
wet [ __ ] coming down upon doors but I'm
really powerful I agree with you a
hundred percent and look at you Liza
Koshi all the way down the chicken wing
gauntlet now there's nothing left to do
but roll out the red carpet for you my
friend this camera this camera this
camera let the people know what you have
going on guys
I have literally stepped into this so
scared it's facing my fears you can get
some of my team back there
it was terrified and it was actually
like to be most fun I've ever had guys
make sure to check out lies on demand it
is coming out September 25th season 2
season 1 is now completely free on
YouTube it's a good time it's a really
good time thank you for letting me have
a good time in bed
[Music]
cut that [ __ ] now oh oh oh are you
[ __ ] leaving this part in it's only
art oh my god I was awful that was an
experience
what is up spy slurs camera guy bill
here I know we've retired the laptop
this season and you all miss me but I
want you to know that I'm still hard at
work behind the camera if you like
today's episode it would mean a lot to
me and the rest of the hot ones crew to
give us a little like or a little
subscribe it would really mean a lot
this camera guy bill here saying it's
good to be camera guy bill
you